Right.
I want to talk about liberal policies.
We have six years of them under
President Obama.
Let's put aside obamacare because it's
still undefined.
Whether that's going to really help the
majority of people and put us out of the
economy because some people are
benefiting now,
but the wages are still down.
What is the biggest accomplishment of
President Obama domestically,
in your opinion?
I think financial reform.
Do you think he's leading president
Obama's a world leader?
You think Putin is fearful of him?
Do you think that that our problems over
the years.
One of the seven questions you just
asked me this hope so.
It's an overall arch that President
Obama's leadership has caused a lot of
problems.
Part of the problem is that we have the
European nation who backed down because
they think America again.
One thing though.
You were right.
Would you just say that again?
Yes.
I would say you were right.
Okay.
There you go.
Barney frank,
everybody.
We got to get out of here right now.